hello reject nation Greg Alba here I've
made it to episode 8 of stranger things
still recovering still a little sick and
my ears really acting up so this might
be the last one tonight and truthfully
I'd like to procrastinate on when I
watch the last episode to make the list
if so just a night data came through the
last episode we really anal about things
like that so I've been giving my
predictions of how things will go down
and the other couple videos that I've
done based off what I've seen so far
there are my top 3 predictions all right
Bob's gonna die I've been in the detail
about it before already as to why I
think he is just really are setting him
up like he's going to die second
prediction is Jonathan and Nancy will
not end up together in the end they
shall go back to Steve third prediction
11 is on the train back cut to Hawkins
and she will show up at the end to save
the day I don't know like where's
episodes gonna go based off trailers I
imagine a lot of it will take place in
the hospital for a little while while
this embodies aliens yeah let's get this
show on the road he's got a live Bob it
kind of hope all doesn't die this is
when Bob dies
[Music]
ha there so so you have to die he's
getting to do cool things Bob you left
the gun you're so gonna die
I know exactly I'm kind of hoping kind
of over there dude okay I think Joyce's
gonna wait for him down there at Bob's
gonna die in front of her we're gonna
think that Bob gets away but he's gonna
die
keep going
guys your instead don't want him to die
get in the closet Bob this closet get it
down a little quieter just say now Bob
oh you really cares I'm glad he's not
evil doctor dude that's gonna walk away
he's gonna walk away
I mean yeah so he's gonna drop behind
him so there's my time okay grab good no
no Bob be mindful ha what are you doing
he's gonna so died ah
[Music]
that actually suck if you died right it
bulls got so many children no it's gonna
have to right it's got right here right
here oh no really has to go out and such
a painful way doesn't
oh he is he is he is getting killed
[Music]
really getting killed right now people
[Music]
[Music]
maybe he somehow survives
well let's not give you access now
Sheriff
[Music]
now really I was really hoping yeah I'm
oh yeah I'm at a didn't hear that it's a
pretty predictable how he died man I
ever died a lot of different ways to put
pivot I don't really specify down and
still at the same time yeah I was kind
of hoping they'd keep Bob alive because
kind of they're doing a Hawkeye thing
[Music]
gangs pretty much all back together
except for 11 who did not show up
Oh Bob you just you don't even get a get
buried that's just too bad you don't
even get a get buried man they really
killed it
close gate
oh this is it's part of the trail really
romantic the guns people do people turn
poor well but it's calle a break
[Music]
I gather guns God you got that stranger
things music huh music
[Music]
god of suicide he's gonna be a hell boy
I was such a good actor
[Music]
Elevens gonna show up I feel it let's
gonna walk it and biking after they kill
some I'll have to love it
okay have it a lot sooner than I thought
get thrown through the window stupid
camera keeps cutting all the bit please
I thought they were gonna go like kill a
few up at least first before 411 showed
back up but I guess that's cool
but hey Phil every cousin I think they
kind of want you to girl knows how to
make an entrance look cool Mike 11
she won't acknowledge any of the other
kids duh I love it you know as
predictable as it is that I love it so
right right I'm out of predictability
for me yeah
ah
I didn't say it into the mic will give
each other
hahaha I got me a little misty a little
I didn't like shed a tear just so happy
for them i reunite for a very long time
really tense episode it was a little bit
predictable of course some certain plot
stuff there are times I was like oh
maybe Bob's gonna die here but it was
really good at doing those moments still
where they think they want you to think
he might die here because I would
question myself like I'm pretty sure
he's gonna die in front of Joyce down
there in LA because she's waiting for
him I was gonna do that thing where we
think he's not dead and then BAM
someone's gonna get him at the same time
though when the scenes the other scenes
the whole interplay was great Bob had to
go he was a great character as
predictable as that might have felt I
feel like maybe a lot of us thought yeah
they're probably gonna kill off Bob it
was a word heroes death saved the day
and I like that the cast is all back
together because his he's didn't had it
especially in its first half had the
feel of how all these stories gonna come
together necessarily because everyone's
kind of just been off doing their own
thing they're all back together
including 11 and I thought a lot of that
Hospital sequence stuff was really
intense
man that kid who's the kid who plays
will that kid is so good I was like
really feeling that with when they were
all telling the stories to will like
remember remember when we were younger
than you already are
Noah snap damn good good actor man that
struggle that you see in his face of
like wanting to communicate but
something's taking over him such a good
actor way to go kiddo
two predictions have come true I don't
know if Jonathan Nance you're gonna end
up together in the end I still think
they're not Steve's all cool it's better
guy and that moment when 11 shows up
well that might have been a little bit
more on the cliche side of how it was
handled I still liked it I was so still
touched by that I think that's a neat
introduction reintroduction into 11
because we've been able to see were 11
spin and how she ended up looking the
way she does and like things have really
changed for a reintroduction
the character of Mike to see her and
everyone else - to finally see her like
her hair's all grown out she looks
entirely different she's dressed kinda
like a punk there must be a lot of like
questions running through their minds
it's a cool way it's better than her
showing up looking exactly like how she
did in season one makes it more
intriguing I'm finally glad Mike and 11
are back I hope they just make it
official man put a ring on it Mike it's
legal in some states I don't know how
the seasons gonna end
that's my last prediction is Jonathan
and Nancy everything else I have no idea
how it's really gonna end they don't
feel too good right now you guys getting
subscribed to the real rejects please
click that notification Bell make sure
to follow me at the greg alba on twitter
and instagram please make sure to check
out our patreon become a patron eject
today all you guys over at patron have
really been helping keep this channel
alive during crazy YouTube's times at
the same time we hope that we can give
back with all the content that we post
there we've been posting daily for quite
a while now and we really love the
interaction that we have going with the
patrons over there so become a patronage
act today